so in a progressive tax system
is there
to to push back on the cost here
is there a point at which taxing the
rich
uh is counterproductive in the long term
so in the short term there might be a
net benefit of increasing taxes
um because the programs the middle class
the lower middle class gets is more
beneficial
is there is there a negative side to
taxing the rich
in theory yes of course so one would be
if you tax the rich so much
they change their consumption patterns
and that has negative impacts in the
economy as a whole that you like you
would have to kind of really model it
out but there would be a certain point
in which the consumption changes might
have net detrimental effects
um I think that's more unlikely and the
more likely scenario is you tax
corporations and and other
um uh wealthy you know people in society
to the point that
um they have potentially less money for
productive investment because you're in
a capital Society so you're relying on
capitalists to invest
so you kind of don't want to be in the
worst of Both Worlds where you've gone
too far for capitalism but not far
enough for socialism
um and my vision of course of socialism
that's one reason why we'd have to take
the investment function away from
kaplers there has to be if you're gonna
make it so hard for them that they can't
invest or they can't employ labor the
way they're employing now you have to
create another mechanism for Supply to
be created and that's why that's a
transition Point yeah
um what about longer term
de-incentivizing young people that are
dreaming of becoming entrepreneurs and
realizing that there's this huge tax on
being wealthy so if you take these big
risks which is what's required to be an
entrepreneur and you are lucky enough to
succeed and good enough to succeed that
the government will take most of your
money away
I think realistically that's not a
disincentive for most people
um first of all we already have
progressive taxation system uh the
government does take take a bunch of the
money away and people are still striving
to become rich a lot of what people want
when they dream of success is they want
accolades they want respect and of
course they want
some more wealth well to consume luxury
goods with or whatever else but at a
certain point it becomes better for the
state to
um to tax and either redistribute
directly or through social programs or
redirect that money through tax credits
and on other ways to shape investment
towards productive investment you know
we don't want a society in which a bunch
of rich people fly around a helicopters
going from klepto Club while the
productive economy
um kind of does nothing right at that
point I think a lot of ordinary rich
people might prefer
the government to come in to tax them
and to try to Spur investment in certain
productive
um sectors so it really just just
depends but I honestly believe that that
most people
don't necessarily want to be rich for
the sake of being rich they want to be
successful and there's many different
Dynamics to that and accolades and
social respect is is an important one of
them it's also why people who just
become Filthy Rich often the first thing
they do is start up philanthropic trust
and try to give away their money because
they want the social respect and
accolades and whatever else they don't
want just their money